Hello everyone. Welcome to a new episode of The
Dissenter. I'm your host, as always, Ricardo Lops, and
today I'm joined by Dr. Steven Vasey. He's professor
of sociology and political science at Duke University. And
today we're going to talk about the sociology of
morality, cultural change, people's political beliefs, and some other
related topics. So Dr. Vazi, welcome to the show.
It's a pleasure to
everyone. Hey, thanks. It's a pleasure to be here.
OK, so look, it's interesting because I've already talked
on the show about the psychology of morality, about
moral philosophy, I mean, about many different takes on
morality, but this is the first time on the
show. That I'm going to ask someone about a
sociological perspective on morality. So, uh, uh, tell us
first, what is the sociology of morality and uh
in what ways does it differ from other approaches
to morality?
Yeah, I think it's, um, I might disappoint you
here because I think it's a little more coterminous
with the uh with, with uh, with moral psychology
and sort of classic cultural psychology than um, than,
I mean, I, the world is the world is
the world, and we have different disciplines, and I
think we're all sort of approaching things in different
ways, but the phenomenon is what it is. I
think if there's A distinctive character to the study
of sociology of morality, it's really sort of an
attentiveness to the, the constructiveness of it. So rather
than, you know, focusing on, on universals, so, you
know, deontological, utilitarian, you know, things like that, there's
definitely more of a focus on diversity, and then
there's more of a uh more of a focus
on how those things sort of map on to,
to group boundaries. So, differences between You know, countries,
differences between, especially like class in the US. I
mean, that's one of the things that, and, you
know, uh, the US and, and comparatively as well.
So, uh, you know, a classic work here would
be Michelle Lamont's, uh, money, morals and manners that
talked about, you know, differences between the French and
American sort of middle and working, or, you know,
more, uh, upper middle class and, and working class,
uh, folks. And, uh, yeah, so there's a, um,
yeah, so there's a, so there's a, there's a
focus on diversity rather than sort of looking for
universal, um, looking for more universal patterns, I would
say.
And I mean, how do you approach the study
of moral and political beliefs from the perspective of
sociology, I mean, and do you look at moral
and political beliefs as being related to one another
or?
Yeah, I think they're, I think they're definitely related
to each other in the sense that, you know,
it's very often the case that, uh, political differences
and moral differences are sort of grounded in each
other in kind of both directions. Um, THAT, you
know, so, so the classic way of thinking of
this would be that political beliefs are sort of
grounded in, in, in more moral principles. But that's,
you know, in, in reality, it's not always the
case. I mean, sometimes, you know, people are trying
to solve the problem of, you know, what do
I believe about this particular issue, and they use
politics as a heuristic to think about morality. And
then sometimes people use, you know, morality as a,
as a way of thinking about and processing, you
know, what is, what is acceptable in, in the,
in the political domain. I mean, the problem here
fundamentally, you know, is a problem of sort of
dimension reduction in the sense that, you know, we
can have views on tons of different things. Uh,
THERE, you know, we can ask a bunch of
different questions. A friend of mine once said that,
you know, you can ask a You can ask
a random sample of people, but you can't ask
a random sample of questions. And that's like haunted
me my whole, uh, my whole, my whole career,
uh, because, um, you know, that it's, it's a,
there's a profound truth in this, which is that,
you know, there are infinite, potentially infinite number of
things that we could ask about. And then the
question is not just saying like, oh, what's your
view on this? What's your view on this? What's
your view on this? What's your view on this?
What's your view on this? It's thinking about, well,
what is the sort of Deeper structure and, and
not be, and I think there has to be
because we have to have some capacity to project
these sorts of problems into like a lower dimensional
space in order to make comparisons. I mean, essentially,
we have to be able to analogize this sort
of problem is like this sort of problem. And
that's why I think you see this, this formation
of um uh of, of, uh, of sort of
like lower dimensionality representations. And the, the simplest one
of that would be something like left to right.
Um, BUT I think there is, um, but I
think there, uh, there also are there, you know,
there are, there, there are probably many dimensions. I
mean, one of the things, um, One of the
things that, uh, that was interesting when, when word
embeddings and things, you know, sort of first came
out, now we're way, we're way past the word
embeddings. But when word embeddings came out, and, you
know, people were talking about how to represent, you
know, language in this sort of 300 dimensional space,
it got me sort of thinking about like, what
is the right level? Like, what is the right,
you know, we would like to have things be,
you know, 3 dimensions or 4 dimensions, you know,
like, you know, there's Osgood's classic work from the
1950s and 1960s in psychology, you know, with um
evaluation, potency and activity. You know, those sort of
three dimensions of characterizing things. I don't think we're
going to get the whole thing done in 3
dimensions, but, um, in our, in our sort of
political work, it does seem like there are kind
of maybe 2, you know, 22 main dimensions. Uh,
YOU know, one is, you know, how much do
you care about people who aren't related to you?
I think that's a huge, that's a huge difference.
So, like, how much do you care about basically
fairness? I mean, everybody cares about people who are,
like, related to them. I mean, essentially. Um, YOU
know, so your family, your kids, there aren't too
many people out there who just like hate their
kids or whatever. So, you know, that part is
fixed. And then there's like, how much do you
care about, you know, sort of abstract, uh, others.
And, uh, and then, you know, how much do
you prioritize the sort of existence of social order?
And I think, you know, from our analysis that
we did, um, you know, uh, on the measuring
morality project that we did, uh, in the mid,
uh, the mid teens, um, We, we found that's
probably an important distinction. So, but, but all this
is, all this is implicated with issues of the
sort of like, what is the person, what kinds
of things are right, what kinds of things are
wrong? Our morals, you know, sort of relative or
absolute. And, and some of these things are more
abstract, some of these things are more concrete, and
it's a, it's a, it's a mess, basically, but
we're trying to make a little bit of a
sense of the mess, um, without oversimplifying, without oversimplifying.
Uh, BUT I mean, when it comes to the
relationship between our moral values and our political beliefs,
is it that, Uh, one derives from the other,
I mean that for example, our political beliefs derive
from our moral values and our morality is more
basil than our political beliefs. Is it the other
way around? I mean, is, is it a sort
of dynamic, uh, relationship where, uh, er, there's a
back and forth between them, or, uh, I mean,
how, how, what do we know about that?
I mean, one of the reasons that we've moved
on to studying kids, I mean, like we're doing,
we have a project that we're, that we're writing
up now, basically, where we're interviewing, where we interviewed,
uh, uh, children between the ages of, you know,
um, roughly between the ages of 9 and 11,
or, you know, 8 and 12, a few, but,
um, and one of the reasons we did that
is because once we, because to answer your kind
of question, The problem is when you study adults,
which is what most of these sort of surveys
do, um, most of these studies do is study
adults, all that stuff is already sort of fused
together. So, like, you can talk about the correlations,
uh, you know, between things, you can talk about
how, you know, you know, the, these kind of
moral beliefs are correlated with these kind of political
commitments and, and, and in issue positions and things
like that. You can talk about all that. Um,
BUT it's really hard to tell how things sort
of grow together and One of the things that
people have tried to do with adults is they've
tried to, to, to study this issue of what's
called dynamic constraint. And the idea being, well, when
this thing moves, does this other thing move with
it? And that would be one way of sort
of answering your question, which would be to say,
when somebody's views on like, I don't know, uh,
you know, a moral relativism, you know, changes or
someone's view on, um, you know, like the care
Foundation or whatever changes. Um, DOES it change their,
their political views? And, and there are two problems
with that. Number one is, In adults, we don't
actually see a tremendous amount of change. And so,
like the idea that this thing would change and
then this thing would follow, that actually doesn't, it
doesn't happen very much. Uh, A lot of what
looks like change, and this is what my, a
lot of my work has been on recently, is
a lot of what looks like change is actually
just measurement error. I mean, in the sense that
we, you know, people's responses will fluctuate just because
of the question, because of what they had for
breakfast that morning, you know, so even if you
follow people over time, there's gonna be noise in
those responses that's not like real signal. So that's
the problem. Problem number 1 is a lot of
things that look like apparent change are actually noise,
and it doesn't seem that a lot of people
are changing. The second, the second part of that
is that even when people change on one thing,
there's actually remarkably little evidence, and I would even
say at this point, there's like, I would say
there's a lot of evidence against. This issue of
dynamic constraint in adults, um, meaning that like, oh,
you know, I changed my view on this, and
therefore it has this sort of logical implication or
psychological implication with this other set of beliefs. I
think people are remarkably good at holding sort of
contradictory positions, because they don't think about this very
much. And so that's why we felt like we
had to go back and, and study kids. Because,
um, and this is something we just started over
the past couple of years, because we, because I,
that's a period where we can start to see
formation. I mean, essentially what we've been doing the
whole time is we've been looking at like a
totally baked cake, and we're like trying to figure
out how the cake is made. You know what
I mean? And we can cut, you can cut
the cake open, you can like do lots of
things, but, you know, you get, you don't see
the process of the cake getting sort of mixed
and baked and everything, and you can't, like, you
just cool the cake off and have the ingredients
fall back out. And so I think we have
to go back further into this sort of cake
baking process to see how this works. And so,
um, what it looks like, so, so what it
looks like based on, you know, what we've done
so far. IS that it is like this kind
of dynamic process where maybe, and this is, this
is tentative, but, but maybe people start with, so,
number one, kids have a lot more issue positions
than you think. They can answer questions about that,
and they really can answer questions about um things
like, oh, should taxes be higher or lower, and
things about immigration. And, and their responses are structured
in a sort of similar, um, in a similar
left-right dimension to their, their parents. But the thing
that comes across the most clearly is that I
think there's a dynamic, what we're seeing is a
sort of emerging dynamic where maybe what happens is
the kids sort of identify with um people they
like or don't like. So, the thing, the signals
that are coming through most clearly from like parents
to kids look like things about, like, what do
you think about Trump? What do you think about,
and I think, so it's possible that other things
will, um, like, sort of grow around that, if
that makes sense. So, like, so some of these
basic evaluations, like, that's a good guy, that's a
bad guy. You know, like, you know, Kamala Harris
is the, you know, in the, in the election
was when we started this project, is, you know,
she's the sort of good one, and Trump's the
bad one. And I think, like, for, for younger
people, I think that stuff can sort of grow
around that, but then by the time you're an
adult, all that growing has more or less taken
place. So that's, that's how I think about that,
that process, that sort of dynamic process. But we,
but without studying kids more, it's gonna be very,
very hard to really disentangle that.
Yeah, you know, I mean, it's interesting because this
might just be some strong intuitions of mine, but
it doesn't seem to me that, for example, the
way that political scientists, when they distinguish between different
sets of political ideologies and also moral and political
philosophers when they try to come up with completely
Coherent systems of belief. I don't think that that's
really how things work in people's minds, at least
most of the time. I think that what you
see in terms of the coherence that is demanded
from people in the context of philosophy, political science,
of course, if you approach political science as if
you're trying to. Established perfectly delineated political beliefs, political
systems, I think that that only works and only
to a certain extent for people who are trained
to do that, and I agree with that, and
I don't think that that really happens very often
in quote unquote real life and even I would
even go. As far as to say that even
the philosophers and the political scientists themselves, if you
prove them enough, you get to learn that even
what they think are perfectly coherent systems of belief
that they hold are really not that coherent and
and most of it, or at least big parts
of it is basically ad hoc or post hoc
rationalization.
No, I, I agree with that. And I mean,
I, I, I know less about the sort of
um the philosophical coherence, although my position, uh, my,
my reaction is very similar to yours on that,
on that dimension. I think, um, I mean, this
is one of the sort of this, you know,
big discoveries, which is totally common sense now, but
in the 1960s, Philip Converse, you know, who did
this work on uh belief constraint. You know, I
think people expected to find much more, um, much
more structure in political beliefs. Like, oh, if you
believe this, you believe that. And it's, and it
turns out that it's a mess. I mean, a
lot of what, you know, he, you know, what
he concluded, and this was, you know, 60 years
ago, was that people were what he Uh, innocent
of ideology. I mean, basically, most people essentially didn't
have any sort of ideology. And what you can
see now is like people who are more educated,
people who are, you know, who are more likely
to pay attention to politics, their views are more
constrained. And what constrained means here is that, like,
we can predict. What they believe about other things
based on what we know about one thing. So,
you know, you know that this person, you know,
uh, supports abortion rights, then you know that they
are a Democrat, then you know that they're gonna
support gay rights, then you know they're gonna support
sort of civil rights, you know, uh, sort of,
uh, civil rights, things like that. So, um, so,
so yeah, so that, so that thing of constraint
that way. Uh, IT'S, it's actually not, it's, it's
number one, it's not as big as you would
think, and, but, but it does, the, the more
people are paying attention, the more they seem to
like lock into this, to that structure. But, um,
but most people are not remotely close to, uh,
to having a coherent view, absolutely.
Yeah, so, uh, before we move on to other
specific topics, let me just ask you a more
general question about the framework you bring into your
work for the uh for us then to talk
about cultural change. In your work you combine sociology
with cultural evolution. So how do you go about
doing that and what kinds of insights do you
think we can get from combining those two approaches?
Yeah, I think, um, so the cultural evolution thing
for me started maybe, I'm bad at time, but
maybe something like only 5 or 6 years ago,
one of my PhD students uh got me reading
in that, uh, in that area. And um it's
great because, you know, I've been studying culture for
a long time, uh, in, in this sort of
sociological tradition, uh, which has its roots. I mean,
you can think about it a lot of different
ways, but, you know, in Parsons, Anne Swidler, Michelle
Lamontt, A Paul DiMaggio, um, And, uh, and, uh,
there's, there hasn't been a whole lot of connection
with the sort of Boyd and Richardson, um, you
know, type, uh, world of, of, of culture. And
so, you know, I got into this, um, yeah,
like about 5 years ago, and I think, um,
it seemed to be like really fruitful because they're
interested in some core mechanisms that I think sociology
has not thought about a ton for a while.
I mean, sociologists sort of do like hand waving
at the issue of socialization. It's one of those
topics, like, uh, in, in the domain of socialization
that will show up, um, like in a, in
like in a sociology textbook, like an intro sociology
textbook, but like, until very recently, you know, people
weren't actually talking about it, like professional sociologists weren't
talking about socialization anymore. Um, AND so, uh, so
sort of getting back to thinking about socialization, uh,
with these sort of concepts of, of social learning,
prestige biassocial learning, or other kinds of biased social
learning where people are paying, you know, more attention
to certain kinds of, uh, cons specifics in their
environment and, you know, trying to figure out who
they could copy, and there's some, some natural affinities.
You know, between that and other things that sociologists
are really comfortable with, like, like social network analysis.
So thinking about like, you know, not only, you
know, are things sort of diffusing in my network,
like a, like a disease might, but, you know,
but I'm, oh, I'm who, who's, who am I
paying attention to? So, are, are people paying attention
to higher status others? Are they paying Attention to
more similar others. So I think that brings a
set of tools that is very compatible with the
way that sociologists tend to think of that, tend
to think about that. And then, I, I think,
um, there's a fit, there's a sort of natural
fit, um, with the issue of demography, which is
very adjacent to sociology. I, I went to the
University of North Carolina and, you know, I've, uh,
For my PhD and there's a, there are a
lot of demographers there. Um, AND so, you know,
I, I have been thinking for many, many years
about like age period cohort type, uh, problems, which
are like bread and butter for demographers, you know,
trying to understand how, you know, other kinds of
population change. And, uh, and the cultural evolution folks
are, you know, very used to sort of population,
population thinking. So I think there was a sort
of, once I, once I became aware of the
fact that that stuff was there, it became sort
of a natural fit to think about, like, you
know, sort of cultural demography. Um, YOU know, sort
of putting these things together with the sort of
demographic tools that I was aware of already, and,
uh, and, and, uh, and, and cultural evolution, and
then to think at the micro level, these processes
of, uh, of, of, of social learning, um, and,
uh, and things like that.
So when it comes to cultural evolution, you tend
to adhere more to the Californian school of cultural
evolutionary theory. I mean, the Dwight Richardson, Enrich school.
Well,
you know what's interesting about, it's interesting you should
say that actually because, um, so, um, Uh, the
short answer, I guess would be yes. Although from
the outside, when I first kind of got into
this, I wasn't aware that there was this sort
of like, you know, the France version and the
California version. Like when I first got into this,
I wasn't aware, but the first conference that I
got invited to, uh, that was cultural evolution related.
It was, was the French folks, it was the
Dan Sperber, um, yeah, yeah, exactly, yep. And so
that was the first, that was in like 2022,
I think, uh, and, uh, right after the sort
of pandemic, you know, when people were starting to
travel again, uh, we did this, uh, it was
like a small conference in, in, uh, in France,
where I met, uh, Dan and, and Hugo and,
and stuff, uh, for the first time. And, uh,
and so at that time, I really wasn't aware
that there was a difference. So I sort of
just walked in, oh, hey, interesting. And it seems
to me like the main, um, the, the main
difference, and, and this, and the reason that this
is important is the, I think the main difference
is this issue of like cultural attractors and whether
some things are sort of naturally more, um, naturally
sort of uh more um likely to, to, to
be the sort of focus of an equilibrium. Um,
AND I think, uh, the more that I've gotten
into this, the more I think, so, so I,
so here's my view. I just, you know, I
went to the Cultural Evolution Society. I think there's
a lot of efforts for people as the sort
of cultural evolution space grows to like smooth over
that distinction, you know, to, to, you know, so
I, one of my good friends, Helena Mitan, who's
a, who's a professor, she's cultural evolution, you know,
she's in the more French tradition, she's French, and
she's in the sort of more Paris traditional work
with Dan Sperber at Stanford Graduate School of Business.
Um, YOU know, so I, so, so I, I
talked to her, and I, you know, and I
have the, the, the sort of more California folks
that I talked to, like Brett Boeheim and Paul
and, and Paul Smolino, although he's not in that
pure lineage or whatever, but, but anyway, you have
this, um, you have the, there's an attempt that
I noticed at the Cultural Revolution meeting. To kind
of smooth some of this stuff over, like, ah,
you know, we're all, I, and I don't think
that fighting for fighting's sake is a good idea,
but I do think this issue actually of cultural
attraction is, is, is really important. Um, I think
it's a really important thing, and I think, um,
I think there's, there's something to it, and I
think if I had to say, I would say
that, um, there, that the cultural attraction issues is
important because As somebody who's who's been studying sort
of socialization, I don't know that, like, a sort
of pure arbitrariness, if that makes sense. I don't
know if the idea of sort of like, you
know, arbitrary transmission makes a lot of sense. I
think there are some, you know, I've done some
work uh with uh affect control theory, which is
this theory in sociology that derives from Osgood's work
in the 1950s and 1960s on, uh, this, on,
on the universal aspects of cultural meaning. I won't
go into too much into that, but the idea
being that there are some sort of more, um,
you know, natural, you know, like, so the classic
example of this would be something not from Af
Control, there would be something like, Uh, you know,
man bites dog is a lot more surprising than
dog bites man. You know what I mean? You
know, that there's something to, you know, there's something
to, you know, unusual, uh, things, or, um, that,
you know, that, that are, that are more natural,
or some things that are a little bit more
natural. And so I think there's a, um, I
think the, the issue of, uh, the issue of,
of Cultural attraction is going to be something that
I hope we can talk about in a, in
a, I hope we can move forward on that
in a reasonable way, because I think there are
two, there's sort of two dumb ways to do
this. One would be just to smooth everything over
and say it doesn't matter. And I think that
is a problem, actually. I think when, when there's
a, when there are actual theoretical differences, I think
we should engage with them. I think, and this
is a tangent, but In sociology, one of the,
I think one of the problems in sociology is
people don't do this. Everybody sort of goes around
it's like, oh, your work is so great, and
your work is so great, and your work is
so great. My work is so great. Everybody's work
is so great. And we don't spend a lot
of time thinking about like, oh, like, actually, what
the way that I'm thinking about this isn't actually
really compatible with the way that you're thinking about.
There's a tension here. And I think, you know,
so we don't want to be, so I don't
think smoothing everything over is a good idea. Yeah.
And I, and just be pretending that the differences
between us and sort of theory is not important.
I think that's a huge mistake from an intellectual
point of view. It's, it's socially very comfortable. To
just not have to like, oh, I just wrote
a thing that's critical of your work, you know,
I mean, like, I, obviously, that's socially uncomfortable for
people. I mean, it's not a huge, you know,
these are, these worlds are fairly small. Um, BUT
the other problem would be just, the other issue
would be like, oh, we're gonna go into like
our sort of separate camps. So that's, you know,
here's a group over here that's just gonna work
on its thing, and here's a group over here
that's just gonna work on this thing, and they're
not gonna talk to each other, or they're gonna,
you know, sort of even worse, you know, mutually
just sort of insult each other or make fun
of each other or whatever for their, you know,
simplicity. Um. I, so I hope that we can
sort of respectfully engage, but actually engage, you know,
not turn up the respect dial too much, you
know, but, but actually engage on these things, but
I think they're important.
No, you know, on my show I tend to
be very intellectually promiscuous, and I don't, and I,
I, I, I don't think that I owe any
loyalty to any school out there. So I've interviewed
Boyd, I've interviewed Richardson twice, I've interviewed Eric 3
times, I've interviewed Hugo Garcia twice, Ben Sperber. I
interviewed Cecilia Hayes, who basically criticized criticized. EVERYONE, everyone,
including what she calls high, high church evolutionary psychology.
I mean, the only thing that for me just
simply doesn't work at all, and I think it's
very much a a failed scientific endeavor is memetics.
I mean, memetics. Oh, I,
I agree with that. No, no, I totally agree
with that. I think that the, the discreteness property
is the sort of downfall of that. I mean,
I, I understand the analogy, and I think for
a time. It made sense as an it was
useful as an analogy. I would say for a
time it was useful as an analogy to sort
of get people thinking in this domain, but I,
I, yeah, I totally agree with you. I totally
agree with that. So, yeah, I mean, but I'm,
I'm fairly promiscuous in this domain as well. I
mean, coming back to the issue of morality, I
mean, like, you know, so I've, there, there were
kind of two, you know, major, um, Um, camps
in the, in the, in moral psychology in the
past decade or so, the sort of moral foundations,
you know, folks, and then, you know, Kurt Gray,
who is dyadic theory of morality. And I've published
with both of those groups, you know, I've published
with Jesse Graham and Morteza Dagani, and I, you
know, and published with Kurt Gray as well. Um,
BECAUSE I think, you know, there's some, you know,
you know, there's some, there's some truth in both,
and, and maybe later we'll, we'll talk about what
that is. But, uh, but anyway, um, yeah, so
I, I totally get it. I'm trying to be,
I wanna be, yeah, so I would like to
be, you know, promiscuous in that sense as well.
And I do think that it's worth discussing. I
think it's worth really engaging on the differences, because
the thing I keep getting back to is the
world. Actually works in certain ways. I don't mean
that it works in like one way. There's like
one law or anything like that, but the world
is actually working. Like we're, like, we're doing this,
like that, you know, like, we're doing this every
day, like something's happening. And so, uh, trying to
figure out what's actually happening is like, I think
the kind of most exciting part of this job
to try and to get your arms around like
what's actually happening, um, is like, yeah, it's really
exciting. So, and it's, it's, it's complicated, but it's,
but it's, but it's interesting and important, I
think. Yeah, it is. So, uh, but I, I
mean, in your understanding, what is cultural change and
how do you approach it?
Yeah, OK, so yeah, a lot of this, so
a lot of the work that I did earlier
was about sort of more cultural structure and, and
motivation and like, you know, how people, how culture
affected people's behavior. But then, yeah, I, I definitely
started fusing this more with the demographic stuff, um,
and thinking about the issue of cultural change. And,
uh, so the simplest example of this would be
something like, um, you know, in 1972, when the
US General Social Survey started, which is sort of
sociology, which I think of as the Hubble telescope
of sociology, you know, basically, it's the, you know,
this survey that's been going every year or two,
you know, since the 1970s. It's, you know, it
was in person. Uh, IT was, you know, really
high response rates, uh, you know, national representatives, national
representatives, like the highest quality, you know, stuff you
can get. And, you know, if you look in,
uh, you know, 1972, when the survey first, um,
uh, was, was fielded, uh, some, about 40% of
Americans thought there should be a law against interracial
marriage, for example. OK. And then by, you know,
2002, so 30 years later, by 2002, Um, that
was below 10%, and they stopped asking the question
cause it's not worth, you know, asking the question
if everybody sort of agrees or disagrees with it
at that point. And so, you know, the kind
of thing that I wanted to get interested in
here, that I was interested in was, how does
something like this happen? So, like, that would be
an example of a sort of big cultural change
that you can, you can approach through this one
sort of survey question. How does that, um, how,
how does that work? And so you have the,
the way demographers think about this is, you know,
there are kind of three basic processes. Like, people
can change as they age. So, like, you know,
people can, and, and so one way to think
about this would be like in the sort of
physical sense, you know, like, the amount of physical
strength I have would, you know, grow up to
a certain point and then go back down. Um,
AND so that's, you know, that would be like
a kind of age effect. And in this case,
the average age of the population is not changing
a ton, so that's probably not what it is.
Um, YOU know, period effects, which are effects that
they're sort of zeitgeist effects that affect everybody the
same way, uh, at a given time. So, like,
you know, fashion, things like this would be sort
of zeitgeist effects or period effects. And then cohort
effects, which are the, um, the sort of enduring
effects of the experiences you had sort of during
your early life that you carry with you for
the rest. Of your life. And, you know, an
example of this, you know, would be like Glenn
Elder's, uh, you know, Children of the Great Depression,
you know, in which he says that, you know,
kids who sort of came of age during the
Great Depression, you know, maintained certain attitudes, um, you
know, about, you know, they, they, the way, the
way they thought about the world was fundamentally structured
for the rest of their lives by that experience.
And that's the, that's the, that's, those are cohort
effects. So when you look at, when you look
at something like the change in views on interracial
marriage in the US, The two sort of basic
options are, you know, everybody kind of changed their
minds, you know, like people were like, you know
what, this isn't cool, you know, to like oppose,
you know, so people, people change their minds. The
the mechanism one is people changing their minds, and
that would be consistent with period effects. The, the
world is changing, sort of zeitgeist is changing. And
people are changing their minds. Um, AND then the
other, you know, possible view of this is that,
you know, nobody's views changed, and there was, you
know, a lot of older people who thought that
there should be a law against interracial marriage. And
then over the years, over those 30 years, most
of those people died, and then people sort of
aged into the population. They became old enough to
answer questions in the general social survey, and they
had different views. And so the, the, the, the
sort of two, prototypical ways of thinking about this
sort of change. WOULD be that people individually change
their minds, or there's a sort of death and
replacement process that's occurring now, talking about like why
the younger cohorts are different is a slightly different
question, but just descriptively talking about like, what is
the process of that happening. And, and this, this,
This basic problem has been, is, is, is challenging
just from a statistical point of view. But, um,
but the, the simplest version of this is that,
um, something like 80 or 90% um of that,
of that change was cohort replacement. So something like,
you know, 80 or 90% of that change was
like people, people dying, basically. I mean, people, you
know, exiting the population. Um, AND so, so, so
it, it just makes, uh, I mean, it was,
it was making me sort of wonder, like, how
much of public opinion change, how much of, um,
and again, this comes back to the issue I
mentioned at the beginning, you can ask a random
sample of people, but you can't ask a random
sample of questions, you know, so, so the only
things that we've been able to study are these
kind of questions that have been asked for, you
know, long series. And, and most of these things
for a long series, the, the dominant, the dominant
process behind Cultural change, not the only process behind
cultural change, but the dominant process behind cultural change
is cohort succession. It like people, people dying and
people who are younger with different, different views. And
again, why those come out is a, is a,
is a, is a, is a live question, you
know, aging into the population who have, uh, who
have different views. So that's how I kind of
get into that and what the basics are.
So basically it's about the clash between generations and
the older guard wanting to stick to the status
quo and the younger generations being considered degenerates but
eventually taking over the city.
Yeah, I mean, that, no, absolutely. That's, that's definitely
one way to think about it. And I think,
um, I mean, part of it is, I mean,
I think there are a couple of different ways
to think about that, that are sort of interesting
that I was thinking about with cultural evolution. There
is a tension between generations, but I do think,
and this is my sort of view on this,
is, you know, why there, OK, so there are
two basic views on this that I think are,
are interesting. One would be, it's just updating in
the face of new information is just expensive. Like,
meaning like having to remain open to experience and
changing my mind all the time is, is computationally
expensive. And so, like, once you've got like a
pretty good, you know, map of the world figured
out, it just makes more sense to kind of
shut it down and, you know, from save resources
and just live your life with the stuff because
that's one way to think about it. Another way
to think about it is that there is an
adaptive element to, um, to this, which is that
you want some kind of people to remember the
past. And the, the metaphor that, and this has,
this has a very few, very few similarities with
the kind of stuff that I studied, um, because
we don't tend to ask questions about this. But,
you know, I, I think about this a lot
in terms of, what if you, what if you're
talking about technologies for gathering food? And so, like,
let's say you have a generation that grows up
in an era where it's pretty, food is pretty
scarce. You got to look, you know, under rocks,
you gotta like fish in the pond, you gotta
do all kinds of stuff. And, you know, there
are techniques for those things, and they're pretty tough.
And then, you know, the world, you know, kind
of changes. There's a climate change or whatever, a
climate cycle sort of occurring, and, oh, for this
period of time, the fruit, food's just grown on
the trees, food is abundant, it's kind of everywhere.
Um, AND so the, the younger generations is walking
around picking food off the trees, picking berries off
the bush and eating it, and that, you know,
the parents are like, ah, you know, you gotta
work on your like hunting skills, or you gotta
work on your fishing skills. They're like, yeah, don't
worry about that. And the idea is that if
the world sort of changed back, I think, you
know, one way that I have jokingly referred to
this is that, you know, the um that older
people are sort of the junk drawer of uh
of society, you know, they just have all this
this stuff that, you know, might come in handy
one day. Um, AND, uh, that, you know, that
might come in handy one day. And so, and
I think that, you know, if that's true from
an adaptive point of view, that also that one
of the side effects of that might be these
sort of intergenerational, um, opinion dynamics, which is that,
you know, if, if I, um, you know, so
it's really valuable to have people around, especially like
in, in, for almost human, for all of human
history, uh, I think having, you know, older people
around who knew things that we didn't know, who
grew up in an environment that was different, and
that might come again. Could have some adaptive value.
So I, you know, I'm not, I'm not, um,
I'm not a neuroscientist, you know, I'm not, I
don't know which one of these sort of views
is more, uh, plausible, whether it's the sort of
information, you know, the, the sort of cognitive miser
view, you know, is meaning it's just expensive to
keep, to keep updating, or the sort of view
that actually this is like for a population, for
a group, it's adaptive to have people who get
sort of sticky, you know, to have most people
get pretty sticky at let's say age 20 or
25. Um, SO that they remember the past. I
don't know which one of those views is more
right, but I think, I mean, I certainly think
the latter view is more interesting, um, as a
possibility. So, so yeah, so I think, uh, so
I think that's part of, of how that works,
yeah.
Uh, BUT do, do people individually update their beliefs
and behaviors when faced with new information that if
so, uh, to what extent does that happen?
It's such a good question. I mean, this is
like a I mean, the, I mean, the, the
shortest possible answer to this is not as much
as you think. I mean, that would be, that
would be one way, and I, I think that
would be an accurate and fair way to say
it. It's not as much as you think, not
as much as you would expect, um, that people
don't use this sort of information around them in
like a, in a sort of purely rational way,
you know, whatever that means, um, you know, depending
on how we define it. Um, SO, and, and
it does seem like people are less sensitive. So
some of the work that we've been doing lately.
IS, um, is looking at, um, the amount of
change. So this would, would be with, uh, my
co-authors, Kevin Kiely at NC State and my, uh,
and Turgate Keskin Turk, my, um, my, uh, PhD
student, and Akim Edelman at Sciences Po. Um, HE,
uh, we're, we're doing some of this work where
we're trying to show, uh, how much does it
look like people are updating, you know, over the
period of their life. And we do that, we
can do this with, with panel surveys. We can
do this with things like, um, Um, you know,
457, 1020 year panels where we follow the same
people over time. And the basic idea is, you
know, we don't know what the environment is proposing
to them. So this is not like a lab
study where you can like give people, like, oh,
give them some information about what this person said,
and do they update properly, you know, that we,
we, you know, for the kind of stuff that
we're studying, that stuff's interesting, but we want We're
studying sort of things in the wild in this
way. And so we wanna know, um, you know,
how much does it look like people are, are,
are open to change or changing during their, their
period, during their life. And, and number one, it
doesn't look like they're updating a lot. I would
say that, you know, between, and so one way
to think about this is, what is, how big
is the sort of between person difference? So let's
say at age 18, how different are people from
each other at age 18? And then let's follow
them for the rest of their lives and see
how much they change. And, and the idea is
that those differences, what we're finding basically is, and
again, this is on the kinds of stuff that
we can measure, which is a lot of stuff,
to be fair. It's hundreds and hundreds of survey
questions, but it's not everything. But if you look
at that, it's basically like 10 to 1. If
you look at the size of the differences between
people at the sort of entry to adulthood. And
you compare like that amount of variation, and you
compare that to how much people change over the
course of their life, like how much they change.
It's about 10 to 1. So people do change.
They people do change. Um, BUT not very much
relative to how different they are at the sort
of entry to adulthood, which is one of the
reasons why we're trying to study kids. Now, that
it does look like that updating, it happens more
in the sort of earlier years of our surveys.
So like, let's say, you know, at age 18,
it looks like on average, people are doing more
updating than at than at say age 45. And
so, so, so that's us trying to understand the
sort of micro level processes. That are behind some
of the more aggregate patterns that we're looking because,
you know, we, you have these repeated cross sections
like the GSS where we can go, like, let's
take a different sample of people from 1972 to,
you know, 2024, you know, and different sort of
this called a repeated cross section, and you can
use some statistical techniques to try and decompose that
variance into the age cohort. Whereas, if you want
to understand the sort of mechanisms, we have to
go in, we have to follow the same people
over time and sort of see like, are they
changing, you know, how much is it, how much
of it is measurement error, or whatever. And so,
yeah, so from that point of view, it looks
like um people are, are, the people are updating
a little, but, but nowhere near as much as
people think. I think people think that people change
their minds much more than they actually do. That
would be my, yeah, that would be my, my,
my assessment based on that.
Yeah, I, I mean, my guess is that when
people are around the age of 18 is when,
uh, I mean, they're still in their teens and
they're still rebel, sort of rebelling against the system,
and then that's when they get across Marx or
Ayn Rand or Milton Friedman or or or or
Bakunin and that's. When they, when they have to
decide, OK, now I either go communist or anarcho-syndicalist
or anarcho-capitalist or pure or pure anarchist, and that's
what's going, and that's what's going to determine the
rest of my political path.
Yeah, well, I think academic, I think academics, I
think idea people are very much like that. Idea
people are a lot like that. I don't know
how much normal people are like that, but, but
many, but many academics are like that, yeah. So,
um, yeah, I think it's, um, I, I think
there's probably, um, yeah, there are, there are these
formative moments, uh, in, in young, in, in young
people's lives where they do kind of make these
sort of commitments. But again, as I talked about
before, you know, I think that the formation process
is a little more complicated than, um, than what,
you know, than I, than what I thought because,
you know, some of my original work was, you
know, back in, in 2017. WAS like, you know,
people just use identity as a heuristic. Basically, they,
they say like, OK, what team am I on?
And then they fill in the blanks based on
what team they're on. So they, they think like,
I'm liberal. What do liberals think about this? You
know what I mean? Like, there are a million
questions I can answer. So I'm a liberal, I'm
a progressive, I'm on the progressive side. What, you
know, what, what do people like me think about
this? Or, and, and, and what it looks like
is, if there's anything that holds the sort of
current structure of adults together, this is my work
with Andre Boudelin at University of Michigan, um, is,
um, Is, um, is, is identity is, is, is
sort of left, right identity. Like, am I, am
I on the left or am I on the
right and filling in the blanks from there. And
it does look like that, that is, if, if
anything's holding it together among adults, that's what it
looked like. Now, what that means is Is that
we thought if we went back. To looking at
kids. That we would find that the kids um
formed. Um, IDENTITY first. And then they would use
that to fill in their beliefs, their issue positions.
So, like, what are your views on taxes? What
are your views on immigration? What are your views
on, you know, on, uh, on, uh, on abortion?
What do you mean, we, so we thought that
the, the, the identities would form first, and then
the other stuff would happen later. And that was,
we were wrong about that. Because like I mentioned
this earlier with the studying of kids, like something
like 40% of kids couldn't tell you, like, what
party they like better than the other. Or like
what party they belong to. Um, AND, uh, you
know, and so, so they're, they're not very good
at talking about these sort of abstractions, but they
can answer questions surprisingly about things like Uh, immigration
and things like that. So the thing that they
can't, and, and, and those structures are very similar
to adult adult structures. They're not just guessing. The
structures that come out of this are very similar
to adult structures. They're weaker, like they're, they're less
organized, but they're organized in the, in the right
way. They're organized in the way that, so it
does seem like there's some signal there. So, what
it looks like, if anything, and again, we don't
I don't know this fully yet. But what I
would, but based on what I'm seeing now, it,
and I mentioned this earlier, I think what's happening
is people find people in the environment, in the
political environment, like political celebrities that they like or
they don't like. And like, so phenomenologically, I think
that is probably one of the primary things is
like the emotional experience of, of liking or not
liking a person. And then the other stuff, including
the sort of team memberships, grows up around that.
Now, that's, that's overstating the evidence in the sense
that I, I don't feel like we proved that,
but it does, based on what I'm seeing, it
does seem like the, the, the personal aspect, the
sort of celebrity aspect of it. Now, how much
of that is just about Trump and, you know,
and the 2024 situation? Who knows? I can't answer
that question. But I think that that's a more
plausible mechanism because, you know, humans are good at
judging other people, you know, like, we're really good
at gossiping, we're really good at having opinions about
other people's behavior, we're really good at having, you
know, opinions about people's character. And so, like, psychologically,
at least, right now, it seems like a kind
of a plausible story that people's um views grow
up around. Um, A sort of like or dislike
of a particular person. And then the sort of,
then the, then the sort of the more abstract
things and the issue positions, the concrete issue positions
sort of crystallize around that. And then what that
looks like in adulthood, what that looks like in
adulthood is like, I'm on the left or I'm
on the right, and that, you know, I mean,
that's what it looks like. But the, but as
far as the ideology of that process. I think
it could be more pers it could be more
personal, which is, which is an interesting possibility that
we're, that again, we just, we don't have the
data, we, you know, we don't have the data
yet to, to really say that definitively, but what
we're seeing so far does seem consistent with that.
Oh, OK, so maybe it's because of that, that
when people in their late teens or early twenties
get across Ayn Rand, then later they become fans
of Eckhart Tolle and Jordan Peterson and and and
start and start reading self-help.
Yeah, no, that could be, yeah, they're reading stoic,
the Stoics, uh, yeah, they're, yeah, no, exactly. That's
the, uh, no, I think that's, uh, I think
that's, I think that's possible. There is sort of
a chain. There, there does seem to be sort
of a chain, uh, there. But again, we just
don't have this, the kind of dynamic data that
we would need. I would love to be able
to look at people's like lifetime. Sort of Amazon
purchases or whatever, like what books are they, you
know, buying, uh, or, or,
or maybe check out their Goodreads accounts. Yes,
exactly, yeah, yeah, no, that's not, that's a, that's
a, that's an interesting idea, yeah. That's uh, cause
we did find some of these same basic things
in like literature, in literature, for example. That's one
place where you can sort of do found data
where you don't have to rely on surveys. So,
you know, some work with Ted Underwood and um
uh uh who's a digital humanist, uh, you know,
we did, we did some of these some of
these period cohort type things with, with him, with,
um with uh fiction, essentially English fiction over the
past century, and, uh, and that looks like it
has similar dynamics to opinion. Um, BUT yeah, I
would love to have, but that's very in the
aggregate. I would love to have, you know, I
would love to have people's individual reading histories for
sure.
Yeah, because, because I mean we have to prevent
the self-help plague in some way or another.
Yeah, yes, I know it's, yeah, I know, I
know what you mean. I wonder what that, I
wonder if that looks more distinctively American from your
point of view, cause I mean, you're, cause you're
situated in Europe. I wonder if like, does it,
does it look like Americans are more obsessed with
uh with self-help?
Uh, MAYBE a little bit, but we also have
those kinds of figures here and that we, uh,
they also have them in Brazil, for example.
OK, yeah, I see. OK, OK. So it's a
worldwide plague is what you're saying. Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, it's like, uh, a black death
level of play.
The self-help pandemic, yeah, yeah,
so, OK, so, I mean, but do people actually
change their political beliefs? And if so, uh, what
factors play a role in that?
Yeah, I mean, I think, OK, so, um, people
change their, I, I would say this, it's very
hard to distinguish. OK, let's put, so let's look
at one example. Um, WE ask a survey question,
um, about like, how do you support marijuana legalization?
And the question is coded like, yes, no, basically.
Think about it this way. So, um, and then
over time, you can see like over the the
course of a panel, you can see like a
panel, meaning like, I'm gonna ask the same people,
the same questions, 2 years apart, 3 times the
4 years apart, we can follow them and sort
of see what happens. Um, THIS is, this is
the, when the GSS had a panel component between
2006 and, uh, and, and, and 2014, we could
do some of this, uh, some of this work,
uh, in the US. OK. Um, AND what happens
is you get a shift. You get people saying
like, yes, like more people are saying yes. Now,
If the real world was just composed of people
who had a binary switch in their mind, which
is like, yes and no, like about marijuana legalization,
then you could just straightforwardly look at those cross
tabs, look at that information, be like, yes, this
percent this percentage of people changed their mind about
marijuana use. But there are two issues of this.
There's, there's measurement error, meaning, even if my answer
is really yes, sometimes they say no, and even
if my answer is really no, sometimes I say
yes. And that, and that's always true with survey
questions. Uh, IT, it's not a huge part of
things, but it's, but it matters, you know, it
matters, because people could just have a bad day,
they read. An article that morning, they're, you know,
they found out their kid was smoking weed, you
know, two nights before, and they're like, they, they
were fine with it, and now they're not, you
know what I mean? It's like, like, for, for
a week. You know what I mean? So, so
that's not the, and that's not the kind of
thing where someone being annoyed temporarily is not the
kind of thing we're interested in. So, so, OK,
so you see this pattern, all right. So the
thing one is just the sort of measurement instability.
But thing two is that in the real world,
people don't have this sort of binary switch. They
basically have, like, if you want to think about,
I mean, some kind of distribution, meaning, like, some
people are like, Never in a million years, marijuana
should always be illegal. This is terrible. It's a
scourge on society. And there's some people who are
like, nah, I don't think, you know, and the,
it's not in the best interests of society to
have it be legal. And there's some people who
are like, yeah, I don't love it, but probably
it should be legal. And there's some people who
Like, hell yeah, absolutely it should be legal. I
don't know why it wasn't legal before. So there's
like a spectrum of this that gets encoded in
sort of survey response of like, yes, no. OK.
So that's, so it gets encoded into that survey
response of yes, no. And so, one of the
things that's tough is we don't observe the people
who are going from hell no to probably not.
You know what I mean? We don't get people
who go from, from me, probably yes to like
definitely yes, but there's also, so there's a lot
of movement, number one, that we don't get. So
we really get that movement that sort of crosses
the threshold. So in practice, what that means, what
that means, and so like, um, Pablo Balo uh
Turga Keskenturk and I did this paper in political
psychology recently, where we did like sort of simulations
of these sort of microprocesses. And said like, what
types of actual changes are compatible with the patterns
that we're seeing in the data. And so what,
what's crazy about this actually, is that the kind
of, um, the kind of inform that, so that,
so if you look at the same exact data
that we have, it's really compatible with like a
very few people having like a sort of awakening
about marijuana, like a very few people being like,
oh, I used to think this and now I
think that, like I've totally changed my mind about
it. Or everybody moving like a tiny bit or
kind of anywhere in between. And so that, so
that, so it turns out that like you think
about like studying and so we've been thinking a
lot about this, that um people changing their beliefs.
You think about this is, oh, I used to
believe this and now I believe this. It's actually
way more complicated than this, especially when you start
to look at it in data. And it's, we,
when we look at these patterns, we really can't
tell how much of it is like a bunch,
like almost everybody changing by like a tiny bit,
or maybe like, you know, 5% of the population
or 2% of the population or 1% of the
population having a big change. So, so clearly some
people do. I mean, like, if the answer is,
does anyone Ever change their political beliefs. The answer
to that question is obviously yes. You know, I
mean, that's definitely yes. But we don't know, um,
like we don't know whether that's, you know, just
a few people having these sort of big changes
or whether it's sort of everybody having these like,
um, you know, tiny changes. But one thing I
can say is that the, the, the amount of
change, the amount of change in the aggregate. IS
very small compared to the differences that exist on
the entry to adulthood. So basically, if you look
at differences in adults, like persistent differences between people
are about 10 times bigger than the amount of
change that we see within a person's life. So,
so, so the answer could be yes, people do
change. I mean I've changed a lot of my
opinions in my life personally, but it's, but, but
in terms of the amount of variance, In terms
of like, like, there's all this difference in the
world. How much of it is like, how different
are people from each other in persistent ways and
how much of it is individual people changing their
minds over their lives. The first process is by
far the, the most important one. Now, when people
do change, what factors are sort of most important
in that? This is really tough because it's probably
question specific. I think, I mean, the most obvious
thing to say is that age, like being younger
makes people a little more susceptible to it. We
talked about that earlier. Um, AND, but we see
some, but, uh, we do see some evidence, for
example, that like views on gender are, um, people
do tend to change their views. A little bit
on gender when they enter into, um, when they
get married, um, you know, when they, when they,
when they partner, people's views on gender do change
a little bit. But in terms of the specific
things that we're seeing, you know, like this happens
and this happens, we actually don't know that much
about it. And part of that is, is because
I've been studying like These sort of 180 questions
at a time, 200 questions at a time, 300,
500 questions at a time to look for basic
patterns. And I, and I haven't like drilled down
into like, oh, I really wanna understand what factors
are responsible for this. But some of my students
have done that and it's surprisingly difficult to find
things that predict. Um, IT'S surprisingly difficult to find
things that, that predict cause we, cause we have
a lot of sort of stereotypes about this. Like
going to college changes your views, maybe a little.
My student, Andrew Miles has done some of this
where, you know, changing, or he's a professor at
the University of Toronto now, but But, um, you
know, he's going to college has some effects on
your moral views. Um, uh, BUT some of that
is probably selection as well, which he addresses to
some extent. So anyway, so, um, yeah, it's, we
don't know the answer to, we don't really know
the answer to that, to be honest.
Yeah, you know, I, I think that the only
politically relevant question which I've never changed my mind
on actually since I was like 6 or 7,
and I, it's a hill I'm willing to die
on is whether pineapples should go on pizza or
not. I mean, for, for. Meat for me should
and I will never. Oh, I think,
oh, I didn't expect you to be in the
should camp. I'm in the should camp as well.
I love pineapple on pizza. So yeah, no. All
right. OK. Team pineapple. All right, awesome. Um, OK.
Yeah, uh,
I, I agree with you. It's there's something about
the combo works. Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. OK, so, uh, I mean,
uh, I, there's one last topic I would like
to ask you about. Do liberals and conservatives actually,
actually disagree about morality? I mean, and if so,
what is that disagreement? Based on, and I, I
want to ask you specifically whether it is based
on them having different moral foundations, and I, I
want to ask you that because actually, uh, I
want to hear your opinion of course, but I've
been very disappointed about moral foundations of theory, to
be very honest, because I mean since I first
read about it. When Jonathan Haidt published The Righteous
Mind, I mean, I was kind of intrigued about
it, but then, I mean, criticisms started coming in
and also I think that he overhyped it in
the sense that he even actually tried to perhaps
And attach the moral foundations to evolve the adaptations
of the mind and I mean and make them
universal and then also the fact that he talks
about liberals, conservatives, and then he had the libertarians
as if those are universal politically and they just
aren't so I mean what do you make of
all of that?
Oh, that's a, that's a big topic. I mean,
I, so my journey was, um, I started talking
to those guys, uh, John Haidt and I did
a data collection project, I think back in 2007
or 2008 where we, I collected the first nationally,
nationally representative, uh, sample of the moral Foundation questionnaire,
the original moral Foundation questionnaire. Cause I was, um,
really interested in this stuff, you know, from the
beginning as studying, you know, morality. And one thing
that, um, Sociologists are generally pretty bad at, um,
and psychologists are better at in, in general, is
measurement. And, um, and the reason for that is
because psychologists care a lot about measurement, you know,
and sociologists, we do these big nationally representative surveys
that are extremely expensive. And so you can't ask
30 questions about a construct. You just, you just
can't. Like, you just, you can't do it, you
know, you're you're, and so, so sociologists are like,
oh, well I'll ask this one question or these
two questions about this topic, and that's the best
we're gonna get. OK. So I really started to
get interested in, um, in psychology, and moral psychology,
because I was like, well, if nothing else, they
really have really good, you know, they're, they're at
least thinking really hard about the issue of measurement.
Um, AND I, and I read, um, uh, Rick
Schrader's, uh, work in cultural psychology, which is the
sort of big three of, actually, there's a, this
is so fascinating. OK, I'll just do a quick,
I'll do a quick version of this. OK. BY
the way, I've, I've also had. Schweder on the
show. Oh, you have back in 2018. So, oh,
that,
oh, no way, that's awesome. Yeah, it's so, so,
so if you think about the sort of lineage
here, there's like, I'll go as fast as I
can on this. There's like the sort of Kohlberg
Turiel argument. Um, WHERE Kohlberg and Turriel are like,
OK, morality is really about justice. And then you
have Carol Gilligan come in and, you know, there's
care. OK, so you have that. And then you
have, um, you know, Schroeder sort of comes in
and says, well, when I talk to people about,
you know, morality and Heinz and the drug and
all this stuff in, uh, in India, they don't,
they don't talk about it in the sort of
ways that you guys, or they don't only talk
about it in the ways that you guys are
talking about. There's, you know, there's these other, there's
this, you know, these other things. And so, so,
so Shredder comes with this autonomy, community, divinity, you
know, paradigm, and, and that the ideas that the
US is big. OK, so you know this, this
story. And then there's this discussion about whether those,
those are different moralities or whether it is um
what Turriel called informational assumptions. The idea being that
like, well, everybody thinks harm that that harm and
uh uh is the basis of morality. But some
people think, so if you think your dad actually
has a soul. And that like you eating meat
in the two weeks after he dies are gonna
harm the soul, then that's why you think it's
wrong to do this, not because of some extra
sort of divinity foundation or divinity, they wouldn't use
the word foundations then, but that, so that was
that the sort of Turriel Shredder debate, you know,
was going on in the, in the 1980s and
early 19990s. OK. Um, AND then, so Height comes
along and he does, I think he did a
postdoc, I mean, you can correct me if I'm
wrong here, but he did something like a postdoc
with Twitter at some point. I mean, so, and
he definitely was influenced. This is, this is all,
everybody knows this. I,
I, I, I think so because I remember talking
a little bit about China. And height in my
interview with research whether I, I know, I know
for sure that when it comes to the sanctity,
purity aspect of moral foundations, he was very much
influenced by Paul Rosin, right?
You, know, that too, yes, with the all the
disgust work and everything there, yeah. So, um, so
he, so he, um, so yeah, so, so autonomy,
community, divinity, and so yeah, so, so, so, um,
so John, of course, uh, starts thinking about this
in measurement terms. You know, cause he's a psychologist,
and he's like, OK, well, autonomy, community, divinity. But
then, you know, it's like, OK, you know, starts
thinking about moral foundation theory. And if you look
at sort of autonomy, you have the, you have
the harm care, you have the fairness, and then
you have the community aspects, which are the sort
of loyalty and authority, and then you have, you
know, purity, which is the sort of divinity, you
know, aspect in, in the first version of this.
And so this comes along, and so it's essentially
like a psychologized measurement-based version. Of Rick, of, of
Rick Schrader's autonomy, community, divinity paradigm. And then, you
know, and then Kurt Gray, you know, more recently
has come up and said, with the dyadic theory
of morality, has said, you know what, there's not
separate moral foundations, they're not sort of separate modules,
that it's really um about essentially what you believe.
And it's a more cognitive theory about informational assumptions,
like, who do you think is vulnerable, etc. So,
so the reason I wanted to point this out
is because there's this cycle. That has been going
on since at least the like early 1980s and
probably since like the late 1970s, of like going
back and forth between this issue of, like, are
there different moralities, or are, is there basically one
morality with different uh cognitive assumptions, different beliefs about
how the world works. And I, and what I
would say is, I think the moral foundation questionnaire,
I think moral foundations theory as a measurement approach
is useful in the sense that it's clearly tracking
something. But is it like, does it, does it,
is it latching on to like the correct view
of, of, of, of what's actually happening? I would
say sort of reluctantly, even though I, I like
all this work and I, and Jesse Graham is
a, is a friend of mine and I published
with him and, and I think this work is
really interesting. Um, I think that's probably not right,
um, in the sense that I don't think there
are probably foundations. Now, what they would say, and
I, and I think it's reasonable, is that there
is a, there's a, there's stronger and weaker versions
of moral foundations there. The strongest version is, like
you said, a version where there are, um, You
know, like, these are like kind of modular in
the strong sense. That's, that's, I think to me,
that's, I would be much more comfortable saying that's
wrong. Um, WHEREAS if, if we could say that
these are, you know, these are adaptations that sort
of that form, these are sort of characteristic approaches
that people have to approach, you know, moral problems
that develop over the life course, something like that.
That's not as sort of strongly grounded in some
sort of like neuro neuro, you know, neuroscientific, uh,
you know, idea of a module. OK, maybe. Um,
BUT I do think that that's, that's not a
super plausible, it's not a super satisfying theory. And
that's why I think, um, uh, especially because from
a measurement point of view, a lot of the
questions that are about purity, purity questions are really
about sex. And like sex is really moralized, you
know, uh, um, uh, by, especially like in by
religious groups. So is it really like a question
of purity? And so people have talked about like,
well, you know, liberals care about purity too, mostly
related to things like the environment, blah, blah, blah,
you know, Rob Willer's done some work on these
things too. Anyway, um, so I'm thinking about, so,
so I guess what I would say is, you
know, lately, I've been working a little bit. We
just had a paper come out, uh, with Kurt
Gray on the sort of assumptions of vulnerability, talking
about liberals and conservatives. And the idea here is
that, like, you know, liberals and conservatives see different
victims, and that's the name of the paper. And
the idea is that um in, in Kurt and,
and Chelsea Shine's, you know, theory of um dyadic
morality, the idea here is that the prototypical moral
wrong is a sort of powerful agent hurting a
vulnerable patient. And like, so like, you know, someone
committing, you know, so like a, you know, sort
of, You know, man murdering like a child or
something, that's like the worst, that's like the moral
prototype. That's like the worst thing that you can
do. And so the question then is, like, how
well, and my, my former student Nico Restrepo Ochoa
has done some work on this too, is like,
is how much does Um, moral judgment map onto
how close the situation that you're judging is to
like that prototypical situation of like somebody killing like
a child, like a baby killing it, or a
man killing a child or something. And the idea
there is you have a powerful agent killing, doing
something bad to a, you know, a vulnerable victim.
And I think that's probably from like a scientific
theory point of view, that does seem more satisfying
and probably more correct in the sense that people
are walking around with sort of like understandings of
where people sort of fit in the space, who
has the capacity for action. Who has the, who,
you know, so who acts and who gets acted
on, who's got power, who doesn't have power, who's
powerful and powerless. And so, if you, when you
look at this, it does start to shed a
lot of light on some of these liberal and
conservative differences where, you know, um, uh, my, my,
uh, my, my current student, uh, Ana Hiltner, uh,
has done some work on like how, um, Americans,
uh, think about immigration, liberals and conservatives think about
immigration. And so you, so people who are, so,
uh, conservatives tend to think about the immigrants as
being the actors. You know, they're coming here, they're
doing, they're doing crime, they're stealing, and so who's
vulnerable? The American people are vulnerable. The immigrants are,
they're, they're, they're the agents. They're the ones who
can sort of, they're gonna steal things from you.
They're, they're, they have the agency, they're gonna do
this, and the American people are the sort of
vulnerable ones who are gonna have their stuff taken
away and they're gonna get hurt. Whereas if you
talk to liberals, Um, they're going to say things
like, oh, well, they're sort of victims in their
home country, and they're coming here, and it's our
responsibility to sort of like welcome them and help
them have a better life. And so it treats
the, the immigrants as very vulnerable and the American
people as being the ones who are sort of
capable of, of, of, of being powerful and agentic
in that way. And so I think there's something
to that. Now, what I don't know is how
much of that is, is, um, how much of
that is like post hoc. Meaning that like um
that harm is like the sort of lingua franca
of, you know, like, so harm might be the
lang harm harm might be just the language that
everyone understands. It might be the lang the the
language that everybody understands or the way of thinking
that everybody understood. It might be the common currency
of morality. Um, BUT, uh, but certainly as a,
as a, as a sort of play, as a
scientific theory, uh, for now, I do find the
sort of dyadic theory more satisfying. And but I
do think you can get all the sort of
predictions, uh, all of the sort of useful measurement
properties and things of the moral foundations theory, sort
of out of dyadic morality. Like when you understand
that if you think these things are bad for
you, if you think like, you know, if you
think it's like bad for your soul to do
this, Like, you don't need like an extra foundation
for that. You can just think that you can
just use your normal sort of harm psychology for
that, you know what I mean? So that, that,
that would be the way that I would, that
I would think about it, so.
Yeah, I think that very unfortunately, and I don't
know if you agree with me on this point,
but I think that unfortunately Jonathan Haidt, I mean,
in my opinion, he should have stayed on his
social and cultural psychology lane more when it comes
to approaching morality and political beliefs, because I think
that for some reason or another, and I'm not
completely sure who exactly. Influenced him in that direction,
but at a certain point, he got very influenced
by, uh, evolutionary psychology ideas when it comes to
approaching, uh, morality and politics and, and then he
also got into that, uh, massive modularity of the
human mind. He hopped onto that train, which, I
mean, cog in terms of cognitive science and neuroscience,
that's. VERY outdated by now, so, and they got
into, and they got into it, I think in
the 2000s, and it's, it's, it was already a
bit late for that, and then, I mean, it
was just downhill from there. I think.
Yeah, I agree that the modularity, and this is
the modularity thing is um a bit of a
dead end in this, and, and I would say
this actually, I think this is one of the
reasons why um. Sociology might be more open to
uh the sort of modern instantiation of cultural evolution
because it's essentially a kind of evolutionary theory that
allows, that is much more, much more open to
social construction than something like strong evolutionary psychology with
massive modularity where like, you know, everything sort of
just is being generated out of this, this sort
of these, these modules that people have, you know,
rather than Um, you know, the mind being, this
is why I think Henrik's work and, you know,
the Boyd riches and stuff more generally has been
like, is more palatable to people, you know, like
me, or, you know, the people that I'm trying
to To talk to in sociology or in political
science about these things is because there's a sort
of, there's more of an openness, you know, there's
more of an openness to sort of like what
we would think of as social construction, but basically
what that means is like, yeah, like these things
can go a lot of different directions, and we've
learned things from other people and we try to
figure things out the best we can. And, and
so I think it's possible that there are basic
features of human experience in the world that tend
to lead to, um, sort of some themes. Uh,
IN, in the domain of moral judgment, and I
certainly think that like, it's not crazy to say
that like disgust is an emotion that that some
things get built around, you know, that has like,
you know what I mean, um, or to say
that like anger. Uh, IT'S something that gets, you
know, we can have, you know, things that are
built around that, that are sort of, but, but
I, but the idea of there being like, oh,
there are these modules. And I don't think, to,
to be fair, I don't think the sort of
current torchbearers of something like, um, a moral foundations
theory would, would agree with or, or endorse this
modularity view. But, but I agree that was probably
a bit of a red herring, yeah, for sure.
Yeah, and I think that I mean just the
5 or 6, if you have the 6th moral
foundation. I mean, it's, it's a very limiting framework
in terms of the variability that you can find
in terms of human morality across different societies. I
mean, I guess that even perhaps a better way
of approaching it even from an evolutionary perspective would
be something like the work that that Oliver Scott
Curry is doing with his moral molecules approach er
or. Yeah, or, or even, I mean things that
anthropologists like Harvey Whitehouse have been working on where
he expands on the, I mean, he actually thinks
that there are human universals in terms of morality,
but his list is much more expansive than Uh,
moral foundation.
Yeah, I mean, I, I agree. And I think
there's a, there's a real tension. I mean, I
want to just, because I agree with you, but
I want to flag the sort of difficulty here,
which is that we want a model that we
don't want models that are like the size of
the world, you know, to, to use the, you
know, you know what I mean? We don't want
to map. Yeah, we don't want to map the
size of the world. And so there are ways
to oversimplify and undersimplify. And I don't think, I
don't know. I don't, it's very difficult to To
hit the sort of sweet spot in that domain.
And so there's, you know, so we want things
to be sim simplified but not oversimplified. And so,
so I, I agree with you that like the
moral foundation theory is a kind of simplification that's
probably not the optimal form of simplification. I think
something like Schwartz's values is, you know, has its
strengths and weaknesses for, you know, talking about differences
between and within societies. You know, there are a
lot of, um, there are a lot of traditions
that are sort of capturing something. Now, I personally
would like to It makes me very uncomfortable to
walk around knowing there are like 17 different ways
to measure, like, moral differences in the world. It
just seems like there should be, we should be
able to do a better job. And I, I
think, you know, if you look at the domain
of like personality psychology, which is a place where
they've really tried to sort of drill down. It's
not like personality psychology doesn't have problems, but it
did take a long time to kind of get
to where we are now in terms of personality
psychology. And then, of course, you know, somebody's like
hexao scores or whatever is not going to tell
you everything about that person, or like their big
five scores are not going to tell you everything
about what that is as a person. So, It's,
yeah, so the sort of right level of generality
is, is, is an important, is an important question.
And I, and I hope we can do more.
And, you know, I've been thinking about this issue
since like 2011 when we did this measuring morality,
you know, project, where we asked, I got all,
I got a bunch of these people together actually
in um in uh in 2011 or 2010 and
uh 2011. And, um, and, and we did this
national representative survey where we basically asked people sort
of most of the morality questions that were kind
of available at that time and just to see
how they sort of map together. And, uh, yeah,
I, I do think there's a, you know, if
I had to say, you know, I think there's,
um, if you wanted to characterize the differences between
people in the moral domain, it's like, how much
do I care about other people? Like, how much
do I care about people that aren't my, aren't
in my family? Like, is their welfare sort of
relevant to me? And like, how much chaos in
the environment am I willing to tolerate? You know,
like, like, do I want things to be very
orderly, or do, you know, and that, again, you
can, you can map that onto moral foundations. You
can map that onto sort of saying like, yeah,
do I want like loyalty, authority. You know what
I mean? Do I, you know, you know, and
you have the harm and fairness, and, you know,
I think there's something to that, like, the basic
sort of structure of, you know, and I joke
around about this, but this is like the, the
Dungeons and Dragons theory of of morality, because, you
know, if you ever played D&D, you know, you've
got, you know, good and evil, and you've got
like, law and chaos. And, uh, and I think
strangely, I've talked about this in talks a couple
times and on, and I think on Twitter back
before Elon Musk bought it, but, but this idea
that sort of This that I that like what
falls out of, like, our analysis of measuring morality
is um is this idea that you have sort
of like the good, like, how much do I
care about other people, as opposed to just being,
like, caring about my my own little circle, that's
sort of good evil dimension. And then how much
do I care about social order, it's the like
law chaos dimension. I was like, yeah, Gary Gygax,
uh, you know, had it right back in the
1970s when he was with Dungeons and Dragons. I
think uh the Dungeons and Dragons theory of morality
is not too bad.
Oh, OK, OK, so I, I, I mean, uh,
we're finishing the interview, but I just have to
let you know that you lost me there with
the Dungeons and Dragons analogy because, because, because, because,
look, I, I, I am, I am a complete
nerd, but dungeons, not that level of nerd. I
mean,
I think some of your, uh, I think some
of your listeners, some of your listeners will appreciate
that.
Yeah, I, I, I, I, I, I mean, I
just said the other day that I'm the being
able to read a 700 page anthropology textbook kind
of nerd, but not, but not the watching competitive
chess kind of nerd.
OK, that's
that's too boring for me.
No, I get it. I get it. Yeah, Dungeons
and Dragons definitely a cohort effect in my, in
my generation, you know, in the 80s, if you
were a nerd, you were definitely playing D&D 80s
and 90s, yeah. So,
anyway, OK, so where can people find your work
on the internet?
Uh, THEY can, yeah, just on, uh, um, uh,
I think it's what Steven Baisy.com will direct to
my GitHub site, um, and that has like links
to all my papers, uh, on it and to
my Google Scholar, so that I, I made it
as easy as for people as possible. Just Google
my name. I'm not the realtor, that's my dad.
Um, I'm the sociologist.
OK, great. So look, thank you so much for
taking the time to come on the show. It's
been very fun to talk with you.
Yeah, thanks, Ricardo. I, I enjoyed it.
Hi guys, thank you for watching this interview until
the end. If you liked it, please share it,
leave a like and hit the subscription button. The
show is brought to you by Enlights Learning and
Development done differently. Check their website at enlights.com and
also please consider supporting the show on Patreon or
PayPal. I would also like to give a huge
thank you to my main patrons and PayPal supporters,
Perergo Larsson, Jerry Muller, Frederick Sundo, Bernard Seyaz Olaf,
Alex, Adam Cassel, Matthew Whittingberrd, Arnaud Wolff, Tim Hollis,
Eric Elena, John Connors, Philip Forst Connolly. Then Dmitri
Robert Windegerru Inai Zu Mark Nevs, Colin Holbrookfield, Governor,
Michel Stormir, Samuel Andrea, Francis Forti Agnun, Svergoo, and
Hal Herzognun, Machael Jonathan Labran, John Yardston, and Samuel
Curric Hines, Mark Smith, John Ware, Tom Hammel, Sardusran,
David Sloan Wilson, Yasilla Dezaraujo Romain Roach, Diego Londono
Correa. Yannik Punter DaRosmani, Charlotte Blis Nicole Barbaro, Adam
Hunt, Pavlostazevski, Alekbaka Madison, Gary G. Alman, Semov, Zal
Adrian Yei Poltonin, John Barboza, Julian Price, Edward Hall,
Edin Bronner, Douglas Fry, Franco Bartolatti, Gabriel Pancortez or
Suliliski, Scott Zachary Fish, Tim Duffy, Sony Smith, and
Wisman. Daniel Friedman, William Buckner, Paul Georg Jarno, Luke
Lovai, Georgios Theophannus, Chris Williamson, Peter Wolozin, David Williams,
Dio Costa, Anton Ericsson, Charles Murray, Alex Shaw, Marie
Martinez, Coralli Chevalier, Bangalore atheists, Larry D. Lee Junior.
Old Eringbon. Esterri, Michael Bailey, then Spurber, Robert Grassy,
Zigoren, Jeff McMahon, Jake Zul, Barnabas Raddix, Mark Kempel,
Thomas Dovner, Luke Neeson, Chris Story, Kimberly Johnson, Benjamin
Gelbert, Jessica Nowicki, Linda Brendan, Nicholas Carlson, Ismael Bensleyman.
George Ekoriati, Valentine Steinmann, Per Crawley, Kate Van Goler,
Alexander Obert, Liam Danaway, BR, Massoud Ali Mohammadi, Perpendicular,
Jannes Hetner, Ursula Guinov, Gregory Hastings, David Pinsov, Sean
Nelson, Mike Levin, and Jos Necht. A special thanks
to my producers Iar Webb, Jim Frank Lucas Stink,
Tom Vanneden, Bernardine Curtis Dixon, Benedict Mueller, Thomas Trumbull,
Catherine and Patrick Tobin, John Carlo Montenegro, Al Nick
Cortiz, and Nick Golden, and to my executive producers,
Matthew Lavender, Sergio Quadrian, Bogdan Kanis, and Rosie. Thank
you for all.